Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday, April 11th.
April.
I'm off 2016 what's going on?
I'll worry. Ah, it's a, it's
Sunday night to Sunday evening.
I'm in the house all by myself.
Uh,
the lovely Nia had some business
meeting or some shit she had to go to.
Um, it's show business.
I know what you saying.
You guys all live in the normal
world. You're thinking like, wait,
my wife says she's got a business meeting
on a Sunday night at fucking surpass a
certain hour. That means
she's out there. Somebody
I know.
That's what you think.
But I'm in show business so it's totally
normal for them to go out their way.
What the fuck happened to
the high head over here?
I told you to get me a little fucking
practice set up then what the fuck is
be clear was playing it when
I wasn't here anyways. Anyway,
she um, yeah, so she's out.
So I'm going to try to knock this out
cause I gotta be at work on Monday for
something.
For some reason,
I still can't say whether
what it is or what's going on.
Hopefully. Uh, so we, uh, you know
what it is, you know what it is?
Maybe you don't know what it is.
Maybe you don't listen to every week,
but you know what it is. So I gotta
be at work on Monday and, uh, oh,
Billy fucking,
uh,
clean living ever since
I got back from Canada.
Oh, Canada. You bunch of
freeze and cuts. I got,
I just got back from there. And, uh,
I kind of realized that when I
go on the road with the Fellas,
we act like we're on some sort of
bachelor party. I don't know what it is,
minus the fucking who is everything
else. Uh, we basically, uh,
you know, we booze and we smoked cigars
in that thing and it's just, you know,
it takes a lot out of me
and I got a bunch of Shit I gotta do,
so I kind of need to be clearheaded
as opposed to the usual, you know,
usually when I got nothing going on in
my life. I mean, I can fucking, you know,
we're going to have a few,
right.
I can wake up the next morning like
fucking eggs or something. Right.
I can be in that mindset, but,
uh, as of right now, I can't, so,
um, I have not done
anything. Haven't done shit.
I even fucking haven't drank.
I haven't smoked a meeting pretty good.
Um, even laying off the internet
porn, I mean it's just fucking over.
I actually got this time magazine
there was about Internet porn in Houma.
I was like fucking people up, you
know, especially like kids, you know,
when they first like just the shit that
the Schmooze kitten hope this shit you
can see on the fucking Internet.
I can't believe nobody stepped in.
I'm not saying somebody
should step in, but, um,
you know,
I gotta tell you if they knew what the
fuck the Internet was going to be when it
was, whenever Al Gore was
inventing it in the 80s,
um, I'll never said that. I
said that. I was, uh, I was
involved in the email chain,
whatever the fuck he said.
That fucking guy.
Yeah.
Number one is campaign was over men when
he was dancing around and all sweaty
and all that shit,
and he just looked like he was so
fucking relieved that it was over. Um,
what a thing that goes
through running for president.
I just saw a clip of Hillary Clinton.
I have not been paying attention at all,
but Jesus Christ,
what the fuck happened at her?
She looks like Earl fucking waiver.
She's like Earl weaver.
She was doing something right. She was
standing at some black church, right?
Baptist church.
I'm going to assume you know,
I don't think it was a
Jewish synagogue there.
Whatever the fuck they could temple.
She's in this green shoot.
She's just like yelling and all
this shit she was going to do.
That's the only time a politician goes
near the black community is when they're
running. They fucking,
they swing by the church.
They make a whole bunch of promises
and then they get in the fucking limo.
They go, let's get the fuck outta
here. Right. Fuck. Gotta Dodge.
And they go over, they do a town meeting.
Talk to all the lunch pail Louise.
Right. Does any, if they've says even
those people left in this country,
if you fucking make anything,
and they get over there and they say
roll up their sleeves, that's whether,
you know, they're talking to the work
and man, they take off their sport coat,
they roll up their sleeves,
you know,
like they're going to build something
rather than just go out there and say the
exact same bullshit.
They just said the Baptist church with
more of a fucking a lunch pail swing,
do it right. And the whole
fucking thing, it's just gross.
I don't know anybody sits there
and watch that shit, but um,
the latest thing that I've
become fascinated with is
I completely leave whatever
the fuck I was just talking about. I'll
come back to it. The clean living thing,
who wants to listen about clean living?
It's the most boring shit ever, you know?
Anyways.
Um,
yeah.
I become fascinated with
how super rich people,
yeah.
Avoid paying taxes.
Yeah.
Just fucking fascinating. It's one
of those things, you know, it's like,
if you got to respect it,
I'll just, certain level, it's
just the brilliance of it.
And then there's a certain level of balls
that that takes because you're fucking
with your freedom anytime you fucking
with taxes, you know what I mean?
Fucking with the government.
Anytime you've, you're doing
that, I mean, you know,
why is it that, I don't know. What
the fuck is that a federal thing?
I guess if you're not paying your
federal income tax yet, Bill,
that would probably be a federal crime.
I Dunno.
I always say you got
to cross state borders.
Do you have to like not pay taxes and
then leave your state before it becomes
federal? I don't know. I don't
know these things. But anyways, um,
just the balls that it takes and the,
uh,
I dunno, I don't like people physically,
other people, that type of crime.
But when there's something
like robbing banks
or tax evasion or even a good
old fashioned fucking scam,
if there's like a,
like an amazing level of thought behind
it on some level, you got to respect it,
I think. You know what I mean? Like,
I remember a long time ago
there was some fucking guy,
he figured out how to rob parking meters
and they were allegedly,
it was impossible to do so.
This guy figured out how to fucking do
it. It's amazing. And he did this shit.
This is back in like the eighties Isam
Shit. This guy figured out how to do it.
So it was way,
way,
way easier to not have everybody
breathing down your fucking throat.
You know, people will be
having eggs watching you
fucking Robin a parking meter.
They didn't have a fucking
smart phone on them.
They'd just be sitting there going,
this fucking got couches.
Is that Guy Robin and parking meter.
Oh his shit.
The fuck.
Just say that.
That was it.
That's all that fucking happen.
Rather than some dose shit in there
filming you and you're arrested before you
even get home. All right. And then
the fucking local newscasters,
they always got to do some sort of
fucking bad pun. You know what I mean?
I'll tell you, this guy's life is
freedom is now going to change. You know,
they do that some other, they
get away with that. And I'm
like, fucking newspapers.
Like they can have the
biggest fucking puns ever.
And everybody thinks it's
great, you know? I don't know.
I can't even think of one right now.
Yeah. But, uh, whatever, you know,
you sit at home and you think about,
you said he a fucking cubicle
instead of doing your goddamn work,
you think of one. So anyways, this fucking
guy figured out how to do this shit. Um,
and of course the parking meter
gods were beside themselves,
you know what I mean?
It was like one of those Scifi movies.
We're like the titanic movie led,
not even God can sick it.
That's what they were like,
not even God could get the
fucking quarters out of this
meter, this meter. Right.
That's,
they were talking all kinds of shifts of
this fucking guy figured out how to do
it. And you'd think you'd like
Ai, whatever, man, you throw,
what the fuck you gonna do with that?
We'll do this fucking meters
all over the city. So this guy,
anytime you wanted to drink, if he wanted
a fucking stand with you and he goes,
Guy,
he had it perfect.
It was like his own ATM machine before
ATM machines, he just walk up, bank bank,
boom. He had a sack of fucking
quarters. You go down to the bank,
you go and kind of get one southern, the
rolly fucking things there, right? Yeah,
sure. They don't give a shit.
Nobody gave a fuck back then.
Nobody was paying attention.
They were trying to pay attention
but not not to that type of shit.
So this guy would roll the fucking
quarters, you know, rose enough quarters.
Next thing you know,
he gets himself out.
How the fuck you get all those
quarters down to a car dealership?
I have no fucking idea.
Although I talked to some drug dealers
about how they fucking, um, or a guy,
a new drug dealers.
Let's be honest here at bill,
let's not act like that news guy saying
that you were in the war and then you
were in a chopper,
some shit next to the chopper and you
didn't really fucking see it. Okay.
You took a fucking helicopter tour
one time, you weren't even in Iraq,
whatever the fuck he said, I don't
pay attention to shit. So anyways,
I was talking to this guy and basically
how back in the day when drug dealers
were still driving around and flashy cars,
cause when I heard nowadays they,
they don't even want to track
that level of attention. Um,
how it used to be was anything,
any cash deal that was over 10 grand
grand had to be fucking reported.
So what these drug dealers would do was
they would go out and they buy a car
worth nine grand for cash and then they
drive it around for like a fucking week.
And then they traded in for a car was
16 grant, maybe get seven for theirs.
And then they throw another
fucking night at the other car.
Now they got a $16,000 car.
He drive around for a little bit.
You fucking trade it in a $23,000 car.
They give you fifth,
whatever and so on and so forth
til you trade your way all the way up
to whatever fucking car you want it. Um,
it just, I don't know, I just look at that
shit. It's like, I mean, that's not the,
the deepest thing, but that's the way
my brain would work. I'd be like, Whoa,
you're so good. I drive a piece of shit.
Then what's the point of dealing drugs?
Right? Or I just say, fuck it.
I'm buying a Ferrari and I'm going to
drive it until they catch me fucking three
weeks later. Um, by the way,
the Ferrari I like is
the Ferrari California.
That's the old man won the fucking
gt, the grand touring one. Right?
I don't even ride around
with some Batmobile.
Just give me one that's shaped like a
fucking Jaguar from back in the day,
you know,
or maybe a Toyota supra,
those fucking things from the 80s. I
remember this guy loaned me his, well,
he used my truck to move and I brand and
I'd beat the shit out of his car and he
beat the fuck out of my truck.
And we both got our cars back and he's
smelling rubber and I'm seeing all kinds
of scratches all over my truck and we
just, Eh, it's kind of a fair deal. Right?
And then we both got arrested for
drinking and drive it months later.
But that's a completely different story.
I know I'm all over the map.
I'm doing this late night and I
don't want to be doing it right now,
but I got shit to do in the
morning. So anyways, is fucking guy,
you know,
if he had half a fucking brain,
what you do is you keep your day job,
right?
Keep your fucking day job and then
you know, for anything miscellaneous,
she gets to go to the parking meters,
right?
And what you do is you start
storing up on the quarters.
Then every once in awhile,
right? You just start,
you start washing the money
with you fucking can. I know
what you do. You fucking,
you go into stores and stuff. You
gave, who gives a fuck? Right?
You just use it to get yourself a
better TV. But what does this dope do?
He gets fucking greedy. I don't even
remember how fucking story goes.
All I know is he just started hitting
every fucking goddamn parking meter around
and next thing you know he's sitting on
like a fucking $2 million in quarters
and he ended up getting busted. But
there was a part of it. I liked the guy,
you know.
So anyways,
this gets me to the super rich on how
you know all that shit about the Panama
papers and all that type of stuff.
I was talking to another friend of mine
who's a fucking law and I was like,
how does that work? Like how do you
get your money out of the country?
And then once it's out of the country,
how do you make sure nobody steals it?
Like what happened to Johnny
Depp's character and blow
and then once you have it
out of the country,
how did he get it back in without
just getting taxed all over again?
A busted and he said, basically this is
it. He broke the whole fucking thing down.
All right. Or as far as I
know, he broken aspect of it,
then I know all you guys are sitting
there right now going, Oh gee, she,
she's going to try to explain to him,
I'm going to try to explain some shit
that was just explained to me and I don't
really know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
So let's get rid of one myth right out
of the gate. I remember long time ago,
a friend of mine had a fucking landscaping
business and he already had a truck
and he went out and he bought
this giant fucking, you know,
one of those things with the dual wheels
on the back and this fucking giant
Bedell who you put cattle in it,
right? And I was like, holy fuck man,
how much is that thing cost?
And you know, it's like the 80s,
it costs like 25 grand, which was a lot
of fucking money back then, right? Um,
for a truck, you know, it's like
10 grand more than you pay the 25,
30 grand or some shit. Right? And I was
like, Holy Shit, man, you can afford that.
And he was like, yeah, it's a write off.
That's what a lot of dope say. And they,
they, it is a write off,
but what they think is,
is that they can write
$30,000 off of their taxes,
which you can't.
What you can do is you can write off,
it's a write off as far as that 30 grand
that you just spent in that truck is
untakeable all right,
it's sitting in whatever you made
that money you made 30 grand.
If it's just sitting there and you
don't put it back into play as far as
reinvesting into your business,
the government will tax you at
the end of the year. You know,
on that 30 grand and let's say
you're in like a fucking I whatever,
20% tax bracket that you'd,
you'd have to give the government
fucking six grant, right?
That's it. So the people
more on Stink, oh,
I get to write 33 in the end of the year,
if I owed 40 grand in taxes
and I bought a $30,000 truck,
I get to take $30,000 off on my taxes.
You wouldn't,
you just be able to knock off six grand,
right? You're not even knocking it off.
You just not getting taxed on that.
Does that make sense?
Probably doesn't cause I explained it.
So anyways,
when you have your own business,
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to come up with as many fucking
writeoffs as you possibly can.
Many his expenses,
everything you possibly can to
lower your, your basic, your,
uh, whatever your income as far
as what is going to be taxable.
So say you made fucking a hundred grand.
All right?
You grossed a hundred grand.
The net is what you're left with after
your expenses you try to fucking come up
with is many Goddam expenses as you can
to get that hundred grand is far down to
zero as possible.
Ideally you wouldn't want to pay any
fucking taxes as far as these people look.
But the bottom line is you can only do
it so much and if you write off too much,
the IRS is going to show up and be
like, what's this fucking, you know,
60 grand for fucking cheeseburgers,
blah, blah, blah. You tried to write off,
you need going to get busted.
All right?
So what these fucking
super rich people do is,
the first thing they do is they get the
fucking money out of the, out of the,
out of the country
because the IRS is jurisdiction
doesn't go beyond the borders.
So what they do is they just create a
company that doesn't exist. It just,
it's just on paper, right?
To say you make $100 million,
right?
What you do is you go to a country that
doesn't give a shit about America and
let you use it as a tax shelter. You just
come up with some incorporated thing,
like who gives a fuck ink,
right?
And then you just have that
company bill your company,
a consulting fee for $100
million or whatever the whatever.
I've up to a hundred billion,
30 40 50 whatever.
You don't want to pay taxes
on whatever you, whatever.
And then you write a check to
that company that doesn't exist.
That's really you.
And then you send it out.
So now it's out of the fucking country.
And then what they do is
they open up like 10 other,
these fucking shell companies,
and they have those other
companies build the first company.
And then the third one bills the
second one, the fourth 1 billion.
It's just got the monies fucking gone.
Now the IRS could come at you, bill,
what the fuck did you pay somebody?
$100 million consulting fee.
And then you're telling me,
yeah,
you paid somebody
$100 billion as a consulting fee.
And then you just look at him and go,
yes.
And evidently there's nothing they can
fucking do about it. So then I was at,
I go, all right, so now it's out
of the country and then this,
it's in this other country. How the fuck
do you protect it? And they, and he goes,
well,
you those countries where these tax
shelters that they in on the scab,
so you just kicked them 10% of the
hundred million, you give him 10 years,
fucking whatever you can negotiate.
We'll just make it easy.
Here's 10 million bucks.
So what I, you know,
I'll give you 10 million rather than
given the government fucking 50 55 60
million at 100 million, I'm still
fucking up 45 million. All right.
So then I was like, all right, so
now how do you get the money back?
Because if you know,
you bring the money back is to the bank,
they're going to consider
that earned income. Like
where the fuck did you get it?
And this guy was like,
they,
they bring it back into the
country in the form of a loan.
Loans aren't taxable, right?
Like if you get a fucking loan,
cause you're already paying interest on
it and everything, they don't tax you.
So they just bring it back
in the form of a loan.
Whatever the fuck you want to do.
I want to buy a $10 million house.
You have this Shell company that's 10
times removed from the one that you paid
for the consulting fee.
Right.
And they can't follow the
paper trail because it's in
a different country. Right.
You just bring it back into the
country in the form of alone loan.
MMM.
And then you go buy a fucking
house and I guess, I don't know,
you pretend to make payments on the
loan is forgiven by this shell company.
That's still you.
I know.
I just glossed over that and if
anybody has more information on it,
I find it absolutely fascinating.
There's all, there's other ones,
they just pretend that that's
their main business. Um,
that shell companies,
so they just act like it's doing the,
I don't know that that's,
that's as far as I can remember that
what he told me and I found that shit
absolutely fucking fascinating
because at the end of the fucking day,
yeah.
As far as what they're doing,
I know they're fucking over
you and me because you know,
the school systems go down the shitter
because they don't have enough money.
There's a lot of potholes
is all kinds of stuff.
You can't take care of
your homeless people. Hey,
you can't build another gleaming
structure for a fucking sports team.
Whatever the fuck it is.
MMM.
The end of the day is fucked up is that,
is these people who are criminals,
they're stealing from other
criminals. As far as my, uh,
conspiracy theory goes to the IRS. It's
just a bunch of fucking crooks anyway.
So I mean they,
it's kind of fascinating watching these
two giant powerful entities fuck with
each other. You know, meanwhile,
you know,
I'm in the cross hairs,
you're in the cross hairs and
we're all paying Elvis taxes
and it goes Hillary Clinton
screaming and some Baptist churches,
she talking about that
shit because she is,
because when you bring
the fucking money back in,
you just don't bring it in
and go out and buy yourself.
You fucking Ferrari California. What
you do is, I mean, you do do that,
but what else?
What's your also do is you walk around
with Nice Wad of cash and you go, oh, hey,
chief of police. Oh, look
at that Birdie over there.
And as he looks over your stuff, a fucking
water cash in his pocket, you know,
and then I'll, oh, is it
an election year? Yeah.
Let me get a take 2 million on Trump.
Give me 2.5 on Hillary and a fuck it.
Give me 500 grand.
And Bernie Sanders,
what do you mean he's not taking any money
from guys like Mike? Oh, is that right?
Oh well, you know, whatever. He
won't get in. And if he does,
uh, you know, I'll give 3 million
to one, you know, silence.
That's what the fuck they doing. That's,
and that's how they, they, you know,
I don't, I'm convinced to
that. I'm convinced as far
as like stand up comedy goes,
you know why they're always giving a
shit is because a standup comedians just
organized.
Okay.
And we donated to the campaigns of
people running for the Democratic and
Republican parties.
Right.
And then we bought a little ad time on
CNN and on Fox News and all these major
networks.
If we did that,
you'd never see another comedian getting
in trouble for doing a fucking Caitlyn
Jenner joke
anyways.
If anybody has any more information
on that or they can talk about,
I don't like if it's really
dry, I just like, um,
I'm fascinated with people that do shit
like that. And then they go to bed,
no one what the fuck they're doing.
And they gotta be thinking at some point,
like the wolf's gotta be coming to the
door at some point. Hang on one second.
I gotta answer this.
Okay.
All right. So I'm back. Of
course. I completely forget
what the fuck out where I,
I ended off. Um, but what I really
learned when I was, you know,
listening to this lawyer telling
me all this shit, um, oh,
I know I say in the balls at
that takes to go to bed at night.
No one at any point.
Like all of a sudden the fucking feds
are gonna kick in your fucking door.
But I think that these guys
are like the smarter ones.
And when you watch like American greed,
what I noticed when I watched them,
all of their fuckery was within
the borders of the United States,
which you just, I mean, if you, I
guess if you're too dumb to know,
you don't realize you're not going to get
away with it forever. But like once I,
um,
after talking to this guy,
it just seems like anybody who just
tries to have their entire illegal entity
within the borders of one country
is, uh, you're just on borrowed time.
So I think when you watch American greed,
what you're really seeing is,
is the hacks of, uh, you know,
you always see these fucking idiots.
They buy a house,
they get all these fucking cars and
they have some strippers come over.
Oh my fucking laptop.
Oh,
that was a laptop hitting hardboard
floors. Come on, come on baby.
Come on. Come around. You're all right.
Hang in there and help us on the wake.
Fuck yeah.
Uh, you fucking motherfucker. Steve
Jobs is laughing somewhere right now.
He's laughing at me cause I gotta give
him money and he also knows this can be
another little kids get to
put it together. All right.
And saved it. Saved. Um,
so anyways,
uh,
let's read a little bit of fucking Ad
Shit here before my screen goes dark.
Okay.
Hang on a second. I find
that shit. I find it, um,
I find all that stuff fucking amazing.
It's really,
really interesting if you
just remove yourself from it,
the humanity of it or whatever,
uh,
and all the people that it's affecting
and kids not getting better school books
and shit. If you just look at
the fucking game that's going on,
it's really fucking
interesting. All right. Oh Shit.
We got new here. We've got somebody
new. This is Joe Rogan's company,
the Great Joe Rogan, uh, from the, uh,
Joe Rogan experience podcast.
He might recognize him from a g,
I don't know,
the first 200 UFC pay per views.
Um,
one of the best standup comics
I've ever seen. All right.
Here's this company on it.
On it is a health and wellness company
focused on inspiring peak performance
through unique products and actionable
information. I can already tell you,
this is written to smartly,
so I'm going to fuck this up with strategy
from leading professional athletes
and medical practice practitioners on
it has focused on creating earth grown
nutrient based supplements and foods
as well as unconventional fitness
equipment.
All based on the latest science
research and conventional fitness.
You've got like the leg curl
thing going the other way.
You break your fucking knees here on it
believes that supplementing your diet
and with earth grown
ingredients challenging your
body with innovative fitness
methods and supporting cognitive functions
of the brain are all pieces to the
complete,
to the complete approach to wellness.
They call total human Optum optimization.
Please don't write that word again.
I'll fuck it up.
Find out more at [inaudible] dot com
slash bill o n n I t.com/bill Alpha brain
instant is a delicious
all natural stimulant free
drink mix that helps support
memory, focus and processing speed. Joe,
you got anything here to
help somebody read out loud?
Better go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bill to get a free trial of Alpha brain
instant.
I know somebody using this shit is
actually saying it's the Shit Alpha brain.
Instant is a delicious,
I already said this right?
All natural stimulant free
drinks that helps support memory,
focus and processing speed. I
already said this, I need this shit.
And he'd cases of this stuff to double
blind randomized placebo controlled
studies conducted by the Boston Center
for memory showed that subjects taking
alpha brain demonstrated a significant
improvement in areas of executive
function,
verbal memory and processing speed.
What are you waiting for?
A,
you got nothing to lose in a serious edge
to gain ignites your brain with Alpha
instant. Try it. Try It for free. And
on.com/bill now that's o n n I
t.com/bill.
Try It free today.
Jesus Christ,
they had a fucking brain cramp.
Just trying to read that. You know,
I like shakes. I like a delicious shake
that comes from the earth. You know,
it helps me remember where I put the
fucking stirrer for it. All right,
blue apron, everybody. You need to,
you need to know how to
cook unless you filthy rich,
unless you got a fucking
shell company, right? Uh,
not only do you need to feel like
you know your way around a kitchen,
but cooking at home means eating healthier
and saving money instant instead of
ordering expensive takeout. Again and
becoming a fat fuck. Who's kidding who,
but where do you start? Blue
Apron has you covered? Yeah.
You don't start with a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich.
You want to hit the ground running
for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh
ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals. Just follow the easy
step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared
in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to
the grocery store where
no more sad take out. No. No
matter your dietary preferences.
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover
and prepare dishes like steak and eggs
with Kimchi fried rice.
I would fucking eat that right now.
Chicken Kay, who's soy soup
locked in crispy wanton noodles.
I'd wait for on that one.
Spice Catfish with pay style
rice and creamy saffron AOE.
I already eat that.
Cauliflower I that looks
like manure many Erie,
Emmy, u. N I. E.
R e and it's underlined in red so it
wasn't spelled correctly or it's such a
brand new fucking word. I wouldn't eat
it. Delicious and good for you right now.
It's made out of a rock they got
from fucking Mars. Right now.
You can get your first two meals for
free@blueapron.com slash bird.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.com.
A better way to cook. All right. How many
more of these fucking things do I have?
All right, we're going to and
to then, all right. You Guy.
Are you already listing to fucking two
of these? Let's get back to the podcast,
shall we? All right. Um,
oh, Jesus. Oh, Jesus.
I got to bring it up. My
Boston Bruins, unfortunately.
Um, after a big, big win over
the Detroit Redwings, uh,
got beat down by Ottawa, six to one, and
we're out of it. You know, it's funny,
we've beat Detroit the game before
and then because we lost Detroit,
get in and do you know,
that was actually a certain amount of
fucking red wing fence that we're actually
talking shit. The smart ones were
going, hey, thanks for losing.
And then the other ones are like,
fucking 26 years in a row.
We've been in the playoffs.
Yeah, it's impressive.
But this year you're backed in
like a bitch. You went in as first.
I don't know what you fuck.
I mean,
because it team that you couldn't even
beat when it count two days before,
you know who fucking manhandled you.
I don't know what you're excited about.
You know, you like the fat chick who
got, you know, fucking asked to the Prom,
you know? Yeah. You all exceeded.
She just wanted to be there.
Who's getting know you there for the
fucking buffet and then you go and home
crying.
That's what I'm predicting for Detroit.
Your makeup's going to be running
by game three of the first series.
I'm fucking with you.
I have no hate for anybody
that's in the playoffs this year.
I think I'm going to want, and I've
always liked Detroit. Um, tries.
When I was growing up,
they never won shit. Yeah.
Big thing is they had wanted since
1955 with Gordie Howe and um,
they one in the middle
of a 40 year drought, um,
before they got a team
around Eisenman and not man,
those were great times watching hockey.
They fucking avalanche Redwings
fucking rivalry. That was the best.
It was the first time when I lived in
La and the games came home at five and I
totally got back into hockey,
get I was original six. Oh,
is the burst up, sorry.
Book could Yada herself. Um,
so this year I think in the east,
uh, I'm gonna, I'm gonna route,
I'm going to root for two fucking teams
this year in the east and the West. Uh,
the, I'm rooting for the capitals to
push through to get to the finals and a,
as much as they like the kings and
the Black Hawks. Just to switch it up,
I'd love to see the Dallas stars or a,
the St Louis Blues,
you know, somebody different, you
know, Saint Louis Blues. Who's kidding?
If fans have been waiting for fucking
ever, they have been in the league.
They're part of the expansion
six that came in 1967.
All right.
The NHL was a 16 league.
Um, before that, right
after the depression,
there was a lot of people that I didn't
realize this either. There was a,
there was a bunch of other teams,
not a bunch,
but there was like fleece
for other fucking teams are
something that all folded
after the,
the uh,
the depression and the sixth that survived
and became known as the original six.
Um, so 1967, six teams
came in Kenya and name
off the top of my head. Let's
see, there was the flyers,
the penguins,
the north stars.
Oh, Jesus. The California golden seals.
Ah, man. I used to know this
off top my head. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Capital's didn't come in
until the early seventies. Fuck.
Make St Louis Blues. Jesus Christ. It
just brought him up. One more. One more.
Was it a Seattle team?
Cleveland barons sits with the fucking
golden seals became, didn't they?
Oh, the fucking La kinks. Yeah.
And the La Kings way the fuck out there.
And that was funny when for the Golden
Seals, like folded or to Cleveland,
they went to Cleveland. Just like the
dreams of all the sports fans there.
They just fucking died.
A slow, miserable death.
And I'm like,
that franchise just died out.
Nobody bought it and went nowhere. It
just went to Cleveland and fucking died.
So for the longest time,
the only game in town I'll fucking west
was the king's every fucking road trip
they had was like at least a three, four
hour fucking Denver didn't have a team.
Vancouver didn't have a team.
Edmonton, Calgary, they had nothing.
They were just out there by themselves,
you know,
basically fucking whatever actresses
couldn't bang a Los Angeles Dodgers in La
ramp. That's basically, they got sloppy
thirds. That's what was going on.
So anyways, yeah, we lost. So, uh,
congratulations to the flyers
and the fucking Redwings.
There was two spots left in
three teams vying for it. And uh,
we didn't get in and like clockwork,
the day after,
we don't get in.
What Boston Sports Rayer,
who doesn't watch hockey do you think?
Piled on immediately? And as always,
calls for the wrong
head to be chopped off.
Good old Dan Shaughnessy the noodle headed
contem self who doesn't watch hockey?
Doesn't like hockey chimes in.
Something's gotta be done.
It's time
based on what Dan, all the hockey.
You never fucking watch. Um, Julian,
this was actually one of his
finest coaching performances
of the year of, I mean,
of his career.
They traded the entire fucking team away.
Basically. They treat they, it was,
yeah,
what they got rid of over the
last few years. Tyler Sagan, um,
Johnny Boyd Shock Douggie fucking
fresh. They're fucking, uh,
Milan. Cheecha was just, I
was like, we got nothing.
We got nothing left. I now
know that Marshawn, we got
Bergie. We still had Shara.
CIARA is older now, but basically, who's
knew anybody fucking watches hockey.
Looked at the Bruins who was like,
you know what?
This is a rebuilding year and all the
way up to like mid March Clo Julian had
this, this rebuilding year
team was a third seat.
Everybody was bunched together.
We hit a bad patch, you know,
went out West tough fucking run.
We lost some games and
next thing you know,
we were fighting for the playoff lives
as they say. And we didn't win. I mean,
I mean, I don't know if
you get, I would get,
if anybody's heads going
to get chopped off,
you chop the head off whoever made all
those fucking trades. But you know,
the bottom line is the guy who made the
first half of those already got his head
chopped off and then you got,
was it Michael Carneal?
You gotta give this guy a chance,
right?
You can't just go one and done a fucked
up with that be they just kept closed.
Julian a fucking watch
for having the most Vic,
the most wins ever have any Bruins coach.
He got us our first fucking
Stanley Cup in like, what was it?
Almost 40 years and then what? A
couple of years later, he does not,
I coach hockey anymore.
Why is it time Dan?
Shaughnessy
why is it time?
Cause it's too early
in the baseball season.
You got nothing to write about his guys
forever calling for somebodies head.
You know, Dan, you know,
I think it's time for you to do it's
time for you to stop writing about hockey
or maybe watching maybe fucking
five games in the goddamn season.
Unfuckable that guy,
I swear to God at the end of the day,
I think he's from New York City.
The way he just tries to pull apart
fucking teams. It's unbelievable.
You know what I mean?
He's like,
somebody wants a mob guys goumarre that
they ended up having a whack cause she
can't keep her fucking mouth shut now.
Jesus Pillco wheezy on the guy's just
trying to sell some fucking papers. Um,
I don't really hate Dan Shaughnessy.
I don't know the guy,
but I can tell you right now,
uh,
he's one of the few people that
looks less athletic than me
anyways.
Yeah.
Any who is I as I was
talking about earlier, um,
I've been doing the whole fucking clean
living thing since I got back from a yet
another lost bachelor party weekend
slash stand updates run with,
uh,
with my buddies there.
MMM.
He and Bart, nick and a, so this
whole week, no booze, no porn,
no cigars, nothing. I got the cigar thing.
I got that thing on, on fucking lockdown.
MMM.
I don't have him in my house.
I think about doing,
I don't think about doing it as much and
I only had one cigar in March and I'm
going gonna try to just have
one this month. Although, um,
yeah,
look,
I'm thinking about only having one and
then I'm also thinking about having a
fucking cigar night over here.
I might do that because
I have like fucking,
yeah,
I dunno about 10 cigar friends
and unless you smoke cigars,
you don't know what that means. But
it's just people that call, Hey,
I'm going to smoke. You
want to come by, right.
So all of a sudden I have
10 opportunities a month.
People call me a c'mon man combined smoke
my in smoking the casino you smoked in
like seven, eight, nine, 10 of them.
So I'm going to invite all of them over
to my house the same fucking night and
I'll smoke one cigar with all 10 of them
rather than smoking one each with 10
individuals. How does that math work?
Right? Then I'll create a shell company.
Um,
so anyways,
so I bought this time magazine on watching
Internet porn and I was fucking up
kids. Like they're, you know,
the amount of shit that they see before
they even get their first fucking hand
job. It turns them into like
these fucking sociopath.
And I gotta admit reading
some of the articles,
like I could relate to a lot
of this shit that was going on.
So I'm really just gonna fucking
going to try to stop that cold Turkey.
You know, I got to stop,
look at it. That shit.
Fuck, I'm sorry. See this clean lists.
What clean living does for you at
10 30 at night? I'm fucking Yani.
I'm ready to go bed right now.
Get my fucking jam jams and here and here.
I am supposed to be there for you.
You guys are sitting there at work,
the last fucking thing you need.
You probably already had a doughnut.
You're going to sick a sugar crash
here in a minute. And here I am,
young and Anya.
Um,
so
what else can I talk about
here? Oh yeah, clean living.
If you try and have some clean living,
do not watch the Lemmy documentary,
which I just watched for the second time.
MMM.
Makes you want to have a couple
of drinks cause you like,
look how long that guy fucking lift
all this shit that he did. You know.
Fuck are y'all good? All
right, 39 minutes in.
I can do the last 21 minutes here
without Yada. Here we go. Here we go.
All right. Um, by the way,
I don't for a people out there,
uh,
you know I mentioned some of the
helicopter shit. I did. I did.
I tell you I finally did that,
that Solo flight that I wanted
to do from long beach and I,
I went through the Bravo airspace with
the planes taking off over here, you know,
and lax came right around,
looked at the house,
flew over the fucking house that they,
uh,
the Horse's head from godfather right
down sunset over the El Monte and then
back to,
um,
oh I did tell you that cause that's
when they saw the old guy fall off the
fucking scooter. I'm sorry. I thought
I did think that I told you that one.
I was just thinking about
that shit the other day.
Of course my fucking headphones go out.
What they would have fucking, I knew it.
I fucking knew it. I knew
that was going to happen. Um,
yeah.
So anyways,
I was at the comedy store on Saturday
night and I was trying out this, uh,
this new chunk that I've been fucking
with for the last couple of months.
And I finally got it down. I said
it, it's perfect as I could say it.
Of course I didn't, I didn't fucking die.
I didn't tape. Of course I didn't tape.
Why would I take that would've
been the smart thing to do,
but whatever I said it, so I'll
get it, I'll get it back. And um,
I felt fucking great about it.
And then today I got text messages from
two different comedians telling me that
they loved the new shit that I was doing.
It just, I just made my fucking day.
So I'm really excited about,
uh,
getting that shit together because I want
to do another special this year. And,
um,
I got some stuff in my act that's funny,
but I just feel like the topics have been
done before, so I'm gonna try to like,
you know, you know, push that shit to the
wayside. Maybe that'll just be on the,
the, some of those topics.
We'll just be on like the, uh,
when I released the vinyl of
the Madison Square Garden Show,
I'll just keep them on that one.
There'll be some extra jokes that
won't be the same material. I Dunno.
I'm just excited about the,
uh, the next few months,
how that Shit's going
to turn out. But, uh,
before I get into the questions this week,
everybody,
I have to give a shout
out to rogue fitness.
Whoever gently was listening
to the podcast, I was breaking
their balls. You know,
I'm, I'm making a gym. I'm paying somebody
to build a gym for me up my garage,
a little gym there in the back. And I
got all my shit through rogue fitness.
They just had the best shit out there.
And I was just joking with them that, uh,
you know, how dare you not send me Free
Shit. I didn't even ask him for it.
He just immediately came to the podcast
breaking the fucking balls and they
listen to the one,
whether it was me and Nia.
Nia told me to get the
regular looking weights,
just the ones that look like iron
or whatever. And I wanted the,
I wanted the colorful ones and
she thought that they were corny.
So all of a sudden I just
got this shipment of these
colorful weights and I was
laughing going, Oh man, I must've
fucked it up. I got the colorful ones.
So I wrote them trying to ask how
to send it back and they said no,
we listened to the podcast and they sent
me some free weight and they sent me a
tee shirts. I, you know, rogue
fitness. I was fucking around.
You didn't have to do that. You guys
are solid man. And um, I can't wait to,
uh, you know, you share your
equipment cause it's, you know,
it's great made in the USA. All good
stuff. Oh look who's here. The busy body,
the lovely Nia.
She gets some Thai food.
Did you grab a Mike or do you want to eat?
Do you want to eat?
I got another, uh, 17 minutes here.
17 minutes to Mike's who
were in the closet. Oh,
why don't you want to just sit down
and help me through with the questions?
Why do I hook it up? Cause I am, I am a,
I'm actively doing the podcast
right now actively. Oh,
Jesus. You know, if he going
to be in a mood like that.
Oh Jesus.
What's that?
He just walked out on me.
Um, anyways. All right,
well I'm going to start
reading the first one then.
You don't care. All right. Oh,
by the way, you know something,
I was taking my dog out for a walk today.
You know,
we were walking up into the park there
and this is before she puked and I
decided to turn around and come home.
She started nowhere where she started
yakking. Uh, made me feel bad. I was like,
Jesus, I hope it wasn't something I
did. It wasn't hard out or anything.
Um, another [inaudible] has a
very sensitive stomach. Well,
another fucking group of people come
up the second they get into the,
into the park,
they just fucking don't say what Parker.
They get on the fucking park and they
fucking take the leashes off the fucking
dogs come right up to my dog and they're
like, no worries. She's friendly,
she's friendly.
It's like my dog isn't my dog,
my dog is ignores other dogs.
It chills and then like when you
are bugging my dog, it doesn't go.
It never has the, hey, can you do
me a favor? Can you knock it off?
It immediately just grabs you.
Like remember Friday the 13th when
Jason was under the Cot and grabbed that
dude's head and reached up, I guess
it was the chicken, the first one.
I met a dog tonight who
just didn't like anybody,
but I realized quickly what it was.
His owner was holding him and
anytime anyone came towards
the honor like, Oh hey,
oh, what a cute dog. The
dog was crawling and I,
and it's so funny because he said to one
of the people, oh, pet him. And I'm like,
no, your dog isn't, doesn't want to be
pet.
It growls at everybody.
And I think the dog was protecting the
owner. So anytime, you know, like I said,
anyone who came towards him,
he started growling,
but he was so clueless that he was
like, oh, was ease vine, just pet him.
And I'm like, no, no, you can't pet the
dog if it's growling at people. I can.
The dog went to bite me like
it actually kind of like put,
it's around my bigger walked
across the fucking bro.
I went over and it put its,
it's put my finger in between
its teeth and didn't chomp down.
But it was yes,
but it was a biting
behavior basically.
Dog Man with little dogs with people.
They'd be riding around in convertibles,
you know, like a corvette or some shit.
Right.
We'll have to leave in 11 minutes.
All right, so you want to do one, one
question? Yeah, let's do it. Alright.
Job a Billy baret. Um, I, we're,
I'm working part time
job and I have a problem.
Let me see if there's a relationship
one here. Why can't well boyfriend,
can I not be involved in the the job one?
Well,
I just feel like I always
give the guy advice.
Well maybe it's time to shake it up a
little bit less. I was trying to do,
have you feel some lady
advice on some relationship?
Huh?
Oh God. Are you going to
go on a feminist rant here?
You know women can answer other fucking
questions too, you know. All right.
Let's get another question that doesn't
have to do with relationships. Hey,
you know, I'm trying to give you a
nice softball here in front of lob.
It over the fucking place. Fucking
softball. Anything to me first?
Rolling your head. Here we go. When
all reality show me there. All right.
I'm working a part time job and I have
a problem related to it. All right.
The job is I work at a fucking ice cream.
It's at an ice cream place in my town and
the second time I worked there a while
back,
I had a godawful shift.
I didn't have all the kinks of the job
worked yet and I was working with someone
I didn't know, which made me more
nervous. The night quickly became, uh,
you know this word Koffka esque
parade. Who's, who's that?
Okay.
Oh No, he's a writer. Is he a philosopher?
I'm going to have a
particular political view.
I think he died in a boating accident.
Communist Kafka ask Joseph Kafka.
I think he's one of those. He's
like a philosopher. J Lo now,
before she goes on tour,
I'm not going to lie and say,
know exactly who can we Google it though?
I really feel like it's a Joseph Kafka.
We just read the fucking question.
The night quickly became a Kafka
s parade of a horrific errors.
I screwed up, orders, stock things wrong,
et Cetera, and by the end of the night,
my coworker was audibly invisibly
disgusted with me and she should have
John's Kafka. Okay, sorry. Chairman.
Language writer of novels
and short stories. Who is?
Oh my God.
He died the day after my birthday
and there in lies the tragedy.
All right, here we go. All
right. Put down your phone.
Let me briefly try to learn what car I
was going to say. Surreal. I was right.
Yes. Um, [inaudible] this
is not an entertaining,
sorry.
Entertaining for people.
Kafka ass elements often
appear in existential works,
but the term has transcended
the literary realms.
Reply to real life occurrences
in situations that are in
comprehensively complex,
bizarre or illogical. There
we go. Franz Kafka. Alright.
Okay.
All right. So the ladies
or the lady is, is,
was upset with him and he's saying you
audibly and visibly discussed it with me
and she should have been okay.
She's in college and Almond Highschool.
So luckily I never had to work with her
again after the summer was over and she
went back to her classes.
But even as recently as spring break,
I've heard she's still
talking shit about me.
Well, you heard this all the
way back. She's at some college.
How did you hear that? Yeah,
they're all on the Facebook. Um,
oh. Grampy I love saying that. The
faith. Have you guys taken the Molly
don't know. You wouldn't, you
wouldn't know Molly if you're the,
we like Molly ecstasy,
whatever. Just an old guy. Yeah,
that was my dad when he used
to get mad at my sister Christ.
Is she on that Internet Internet?
Um,
it's almost summer again and I'm almost
definitely going to have to face or if I
work regularly, if I do, I know for a
fact I'll fuck things up immediately.
Purely from anxiety,
anxiety. Dude, you should be
like the fucking older wiser guy.
Crushing it and then you fucking
banger confidence in my, wait what?
What do you mean banger? It's all there.
Why do you what? What is all there?
You can make your remarks. You
get two straws. You know why?
Cause she's the older woman. Right. And
she has to be tamed by getting that deck.
Is that what it is? I
didn't say that. You did.
No, I willing go after the
confidence and then get banger. Yeah,
because your life is like a fucking movie
from the 1920s bill where the guy is
slapping a woman around. I was like get
it together to see and she's hysterical.
He completely fucked up person.
This is like one of those coming of
age movies weren't the begin beginning.
The nerds, look, you'll walk away from me.
The NERC is looking at the cheerleader
and she's dating the impossible Dick with
the blonde wavy hair, right?
Somebody does a fucking triple Lindy.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. I went sideways.
Huh? The fuck just happened there.
Okay
listen cause I'm not going to be able
to get a word in and defense what I was
saying, right? He makes an ass
out of himself in front of this.
You know they sold a fucking broad.
All right. See this isn't sexist.
Now you come back, you're a little
older, a little wiser, right?
You're a year older, you still growing,
you filled out a little bit, right?
All of a sudden you're crushing it.
He make it a fucking couple banana splits
in a smoothie all at the same time and
she's just like, wow, this isn't the
man that I left the year. You know,
the year before, all of a sudden you
guys are working closely. You know,
ice cream is always romantic.
What kind of fucked of advice that
you get given anything and fight.
I'm telling this kid to fuck.
You can shake it off. He
goes, if I don't work often,
I could lose my job as we've got more
employees than we need and I really have a
great setup now that I've learned it,
the work is easy.
I basically pick my own hours and
my bosses by far the sweetest,
racist homophobe I've ever met in my life.
Any ideas besides the obvious murder?
He said your stand up is kill.
I hope I can see performed
sometime. Yeah, dude,
you gotta you gotta grow a Dick
here, man. You're the fucking man.
You've been there for a year. You know
what's going on. Just be like a, I dunno.
Just, I don't know. What do you, is
this, do you have a crush on this woman?
If she's not going to fuck you,
then what?
Do you care what she
thinks is that bad deal?
Yes.
What is fucking has to do with it?
Does have competence in yourself
and do the job. Also, this is,
this is a high school
person that's writing in.
This is somebody who's making ice cream
cones and he's scared out of his mind
about some woman who is not
easy and he's not even fucking,
he doesn't want to ask her out.
What is the problem?
She's going to yell at you about
the way you put the fucking yeah.
Cherries on stuff because as
a job and he's in, you know,
worried about how he's going to perceive
you as one of those like to be at that
age where you know every little thing
you know means disaster and the bigger
picture. Oh, so is he, cause it's
just a job a little bit. Yeah.
I think you're worried a little too
much about nothing. Just do your job,
do your thing,
don't even worry about it.
And there's plenty of other
jobs out there by the way,
and you should just be totally,
yeah.
Cocky,
which comes in
what a bitch. Yeah, I'm
sure that'll go real well.
Be a float.
Float is how long do [inaudible]
kiss with the little peace sign? No,
no honey. Yeah. Ice
Cream. We had to decide
we pussy or nothing.
Jesus Christ pushing all the chips.
And this is the world series of poker.
All right. Hey there, Billy boy.
I'm a new listener to your podcast,
but a long time fan of you stand up.
I was wondering if you could help
me out with a dilemma I'm facing.
So my weed dealer put the moves on me.
My last time I was at our place,
uh,
nothing came of it,
but I could tell she was trying
to get me to fucker until now.
I thought it was weird that she began
sell me pot for practically nothing.
Hm. Hm Hm hm. Wow.
She's cool.
And I've hung out with her at her place
many times to just smoke weed just,
just as well.
I'm single,
so I have no problem getting some
strange pussy that falls into my lap.
The problem is that she's a very heavy,
broad and completely unattractive.
Yeah.
Oh.
Gvh. But she sells the best weed
in the area. Dude, this is fucking,
this has all the makings of the
great first 10 pages of a script.
We've established who the characters are.
Oh yeah. Now we've got the Rabo
super far with this premise.
Oh God, I love, you know
what? I love to do that.
You know that guy can help it.
You know that guys just want to fuck you.
Women know that.
Use it to your advantage to get
shit and then when we admit that,
but that's what we want to do.
Look, go put good dude. Oh my God.
I really wish someone would tell a
story about a guy who was getting thrown
pussy left and right and
doesn't know what to do with it.
And it's like a coming of age and I'm
sure he's also fighting with his friends a
little bit about leg. What
door? We're going to stay in
and go. This is hilarious.
He's got this heavy bride that he's not
attracted to. Who's fucking weed dealer?
Yeah, she's got the best weed. Yeah, he
knows he wants, she wants to fuck them.
What was the rest of the story? Does
he want, this is the fuck come on.
That's Rogan would crush this.
Hmm.
Oh, you are in it. You know what?
You're hungry. You're like him.
When that snickers commercial you are
where Seth Rogan would write a phenomenal
transcendent script that Jonah Hill would
act out and it would just be like, wow,
is this what it's like?
Okay,
what is wrong with you?
I like all of those people.
And I like those movies.
You don't like hot tub time machine like
to meet Chubby in awkward and not know
what to do with your life. Oh, what
are you way being a jerk? I don't know.
You're being a jerk,
right? Yeah. You're hungry.
I am being a little bit of
a generic apologized to Seth
Rogen mobile. I'm a little
okay. Yeah, you are. You're a little
out of sorts here. Okay. All right.
You leave you burning bridges in this
town, Sweetie. Let me tell you something.
Those bridges don't come back,
but she sells the best weed in the area.
I don't want,
I don't want to not fucker
and then ever cut me off,
but at the same time I feel that I,
if I do fucker,
then I'm no better than an addicted crack
whore doing a line off some fat guy's
Dick Maybe. Uh, so guess what,
when it comes down to what do I
fuck my ugly drug dealer for good,
cheap we do.
Or do I just find a new dealer
with super urban pay more money.
Thanks. Hope all is well with you,
ginger. Fuck Cause Shit. Ginger. Fuck.
Um, have you ever had any of
suppression? Don't shit where you eat.
Yeah.
Don't fuck your weed dealer.
Yeah. Don't just don't fuck her. This is
a business relationship. Keep it business.
Should he like lie and start talking
about how we as a girlfriend? No.
Just buy weed from her and like, just let
it be business. Stop Smoking with the,
and also like, I mean, maybe
she's desperate for your cock,
but maybe you're like reading into it.
She might be trying to
fuck you and the next dude
[inaudible] she's a drug dealer.
She's hustling,
she's hustling for like customers.
She's hustling for Dick. Like,
don't get excited. You know, you're
not the only one bra, so you think
we'll wait for next to nothing. If she
does that. She's not gonna make any money.
True. She's making it in
other ways. I don't know.
I feel like just don't
fuck your weed dealer.
That just sounds like a disaster written
all over it or get yourself a really
good connect.
Now have that in your back pocket.
So if you do decide that the only reason
why you would fuck your weed dealer is
if you actually want to fuck her,
not because you're so desperate
for the best we'd ever have.
You really had the best weed
and like your entire city,
probably not so calm down.
Don't back dealer. Uh Huh.
I mean, you know, you're kinda into
the habit. You're not just going, hey,
can I get a hit off that when you fucking
go in there week after week to the
point that the
we dealers are a dime a dozen
though, there's, it's not
like it's a special time.
Just say it. This fucking chick is,
he's, he's buying so much weed off from,
she's developing feelings for,
she's not,
he might be cute, he's crushed.
But like, it's not that. It's,
my point is it's not that serious.
Don't fuck your weed dealer unless you
want to have a problem with your weed
dealer and you didn't want to achieve.
You don't want to have a problem
with drug deal. Trust me,
we dealer wants to fuck one
of her customers. Course.
I completely believe it.
I'm just saying just don't, don't
go there. It's not worth it.
That's my bottom line. She's usually
not this grumpy. You guys. Alright.
Grumpy old boyfriend,
texts wife.
Oh Billy cheeseballs. Where'd
that come from? I don't know.
Just fucking make up names
for me. Oh, okay. All right.
Very happily married for 25 years to
the hottest wife and mother of our three
sons.
She's in spectacular shape and beautiful
while on vacation in palm springs.
Bang. Right. Just keep yourself in shape.
Yeah. We're visual animals.
We're visual animals.
I know there's a reason why all those gay
guys are walking around with six packs
because they know what
they're trying to attract.
Yeah.
Don't bring the gaze into,
do you think all those gay guys want to
go to the gym that much? They have to.
If they don't, that's the end of the Dick
Train and they know it. They know it.
All right.
So anyways,
while on vacation in Palm Springs,
I caught a glimpse of her phone
screen and saw text from PB.
Pb was asking,
how's the weather?
So I asked her who PB is after a
little persuasion. She replied,
it's Dave.
Dave is a boyfriend from her high
school years and he is a former fiance.
This is awful.
She promised it was nothing.
I asked if they'd seen each other
underneath the different name though.
Yeah.
That's pretty suspect when you have
the person's name saved under an alias.
Pb was p beaming.
Wait is the pain is brilliant.
Brilliant Penis.
She's dyslexic.
Penis Babe.
Penis,
pussy banger maybe.
I'm sure it's something in between that
it was a capital p and then a lowercase B.
I don't know why he did it.
I don't know if you guys
have any suggestions what
PB would stand for. Come on.
And what social media is
all about is he goes, uh,
she promised it was nothing.
I asked if,
if they had seen each other or
slept together. She said, no,
I believe her. Okay. Oh, Jesus.
It's a pharmacy. Her
fiance. Does he mean now?
I guess now or maybe I
just want to believe her.
She is otherwise a very honest person.
Well,
I sent Dave a text and here's what I said.
Oh,
beautiful.
I'm only going to say this once.
You're nothing but a sleazy cock sucker.
You've crossed the line of decency.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Or better yet go choke to
death on some poor. Yeah,
something that he's Dick. Wait,
what? So it's a, it's a homophobic.
They was upset. Okay. Never communicate
with my wife capital letters ever.
If you pursue her in any way,
I'll cut your dick off with a rusty saw
blade and shove it down your throat.
I hope you're getting the message
here. His reply. Understood.
This is the last text
name and number deleted.
Okay.
My question to you is,
was I harsh enough with,
and I'm not sure what to do with my wife.
She deleted him from our context
and she said she has no need to ever
communicate with him again.
What are your thoughts?
Well,
I think you need to let it
be then. I mean, I, that was,
I have to say that was masterful.
All that text that he sent to PB,
Aka Dave. I think he got the message
with that one now. What do you think? Uh,
yeah.
So do you think she banged him? No,
she was probably setting, flirting,
borderline inappropriate text messages.
[inaudible] years of those beautiful
of the day. I took you to prom.
Okayi like that type of shit.
Why are you [inaudible] than
that? I don't fucking know.
I [inaudible] you bill barr.
Probably what it said.
Something like that. So hear me,
cause you know how you are,
you probably would've said some
inappropriate shit ever taxed. I mean,
that's what, yeah. Is that
with texting is, it's,
it's how do I, how do I, how
do I get to the texting to
please explain how texting
works. All right. Advice from
a, for a fellow ginger. Oh,
moving right along,
right along a fellow Cinzia.
Here I am a decision to make and would
appreciate some advice from a wise and
experienced man like you.
Ever since I was a kid. Oh,
you've just every fucking thing.
Ever since I was a kid,
I've wanted to be an airline pilot.
I'm 19 years old and I'm graduating
from high school in December. Yes.
Here we finish high school later.
I was just going to say, is that when they
graduate from high school and Finland?
Yeah. Later. Then you
guys in Mirka. Alright.
I have til the end of the year
to decide what I want to study.
I've always had a plan after high school.
I would want to uh,
go to a flight academy and become a pilot.
But now I've started to question if that's
what I really want to do for a living
living. I mean an airline
pilot is an incredible job,
absolutely love flying and
we get to travel a bunch of,
see all kinds of amazing places,
et Cetera.
Plus I would get to the sun every day
without burning my Nordic ultra pasty,
pasty skin. Um, captain makes six figures,
which is plenty enough for
me since I'm not into money.
My only problem with being a pilot is
that I would never be completely free.
Meaning that for the rest of my life,
working for some other douchebag,
uh, would, would decide for me when I
can come to work and where I can fly.
The idea of being tied up to a company
and having some con making all the
decisions for me scares the
shit out of me when I'm older.
I want to be able to do things on an
impulse without asking permission from uh,
some capital,
those other men also pilots,
but you're just over there taking
pictures of Shit in you. Um,
also pilots spent a lot of time away
from home and some day when I start a
family and have kids, I want to spend
as much time as possible with them.
So that could be a problem as well.
Flying planes for living
would be a dream job,
but it would get in the way of my other
dream of being completely my own man and
free. What do you think? Should
I go study something else? No.
What you should do is still
be into the aviation thing.
You just figure out a way to do
what you want to do within aviation.
Okay. I will equate it to the job
that I have. I am a standup comedian,
which opens up all these doors
into the entertainment world,
which a lot of them you think you want
to run through until you get to the other
side. And then you realize what you're
talking about is like, holy fuck,
I thought I had the world by the balls.
If I got this,
I thought I would be the pimp.
And then you realize that you're
actually the whore. So you have to,
um,
what I would do if I was you is I
would still go to flight school.
I would learn how to fly.
And then when I would do is rather
than going flying for some commercial
airline, there's gotta be some
other cool shit that you can do,
like flying for sightseeing tours.
You're not into money, right?
Maybe you do that and maybe you end up
having that business and other people fly
for you and you get to fly around.
Um, what other jobs are they?
There's fighting forest fires,
you know,
you do that and like helicopters and
planes and that type of shit. Yeah.
Um, listen, just by being a pilot already,
you got some sort of
renegade spirit in your,
so I'm sure there's plenty of fucking
jobs that you can get in aviation.
I think in pretty much any job there's,
there's a way to be in the matrix and
then there's a way to be outside. Like,
you know, he's a renegade. That one, you
know, don't get tied down with that guy.
You can definitely do it. Right.
What do you think? Yes. Yeah.
So he should still be a pilot to do you
love to fly. It's what you wanna do. Um,
but you know, there's, there's all kinds
of shit you can fly for fucking airline,
make your money and then leave
and then go do something else.
Like start your own business. I don't
know. You're laughing at me right now.
He's 19.
He's got the whole war he's got,
he's got the world by the fucking short
hairs and all. Sounds. It all sounds good.
I was listening to a
podcast from wild back then.
You were shitting on the
NFL having games in London.
He said those games
are huge things for us.
European football fans
and believe it or not,
there are tons of football
fans here in Europe. Uh,
the Games always sell and I felt football
sells out there. Who knows? All right,
here's new. Who, whose, here's
the last one. I'm stuttering here.
Okay. Guess what? I just
time traveled in the podcast.
Let me give you a second to just wrap
your head around this because I know it's
always weird when this happens.
I actually finished out the
podcast with the lovely near,
but my fucking batteries wore
out and I didn't even notice.
We had a nice debate. She
fucking trashed me. Ah,
what are you going to do? Um, so let me,
I don't even know where to pick up here.
I've got two more reads to do and I think
I have another question. I'm not sure.
So let me, uh, all right.
Dollar Shave club, everybody.
I know this is fucking weird.
Sorry to just slam your fucking brain
against the inside of your skull there.
Um, all right. Dollar Shave Club.
It's Monday morning. Not by the way.
That's why twice sound a little
more fresh. No Yon and fro freckles.
All right to always shave club.
Dollar Shave club.com has a special
offer for new members who join today.
You'll get a free month of the executive
razor when you buy a tube of Dr calvers
. I got to, I'm going to say Carvey
for the Dr Covey's easy shave bad.
Whenever I hear that executive razor,
I just pictures like, you know,
you have the dress shirt on with boxers
and then you'd dress socks with soc
artists. Just shaving with it.
I've got a fire. So more time.
All right.
This is the first time they've ever done
something like this and once you tried
dollar shave club.com you'll be,
you will become a proud member
like millions of others.
One reason is because they deliver amazing
razors right to your door for a third,
the price of what greedy
razor corporations charge.
That means when you join
DSC dollar shave club, um,
you can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
You'll get a first class shave when you
use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet.
What Martin Shade.
You're looking at man or
didn't judge another man by
the size of it. I mean that,
that fucking Michael Douglas greed
is good movie Wall Street. All right.
Another reason is Dr Covey's easy shave
butter using it with the executive makes
the blade glide gently for
the smoothest shave ever.
Dr Carver's shave butter isn't
your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula
with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin unbelievably soft
and smooth. Jesus Christ. We got it.
How many times you can see how
smooth it is, like a baby's ass. Uh,
call to call to action.
And right now,
new members who buy a
tube of shave butter,
get the executive radio razor for free.
They've never done this before.
Take advantage of it.
And it's only available by going
to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar
dollar shave club.com/berg.
Um, MVMT watches. All right,
it's been a few weeks since I cracked
open these sharp looking movement.
Watch for not, it's been a
couple of months. Stop putting
words in my mouth. MMM.
All right.
As promised,
the quality's watches are there for an
awesome price in the style department.
The compliments I get on this thing are
really unbelievable considering I don't
wear it now I'm wearing it.
Describe your watch. Well,
I'm wearing the fucking
watch I always had,
cause I'm a grownup and I can afford a
watch because I spent 24 fucking years
and strip malls.
I can actually afford one.
But back in the day I'm gonna
Redo this copy. All right.
When I couldn't afford a watch, when I
stayed in that broken bed, net fucked up,
cabin up and chill coot
Charlie's and Alaska,
I would have worn a watch like this and
they would have been like, God damn it,
this guy's a pro. I hope
they gave him a good bed. Um,
if you hadn't had the chance
to experience how movement, uh,
how a movement watch fits around your
wrists, this is your chance movement.
Watch watches start at just 95 bucks.
It looks like a $700 watch.
I'm not going to let you,
she when movement cut out the middle
man with the huge big brand mark ups,
the price of a stylist watch
finally got affordable.
Imagine that a watch with a d with
department store quality for a fraction of
the price movement has grown organically
purely by supporters. Like you said,
join there more than 1 million social
media followers and get a movement watch
today.
Um,
go to MVMT watches.com/burn they'll
give you 15% off your entire purchase.
That's m the empty Michael Victor,
Michael Tango,
watches.com/burr and there
is one quick more. Last one,
stamps.com mailing and shipping are a
routine part of running your business and
important keeps your operations going.
But if you're making constant
trips to the post office,
that's a routine you need to change.
There's much more convenient way and
that stamps.com stamps.com brings all the
services of the post office right,
your desk,
buy and print official us postage
using your own computer and printer.
You'll never waste valuable time going
to the God damn post office again.
So you can focus on what really matters.
Trying to bang the chicken,
the cubicle next to you
and growing your business.
I use stamps.com anytime I
send out any of my posters,
I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name, birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus a $110 bonus offers
that includes postage and a digital
scale scale. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else, click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
Berge
Jesus
Christ. All right. Um, okay.
The last question that I actually did
with the lovely Nia and now we're fucking
wage gap myth.
MMM.
Oh, did this spark a debate
a deal? Dear Billy Baru,
I was one of the fortunate and
audience members of your epic terrorist
performance. You crushed it. My
opinion. Thank you very much.
He said the wage gap statistic.
MMM.
You said I wanted to debunk a myth for
you, the wage gap statistic. You know,
there's this thing right now that
they say that a woman gets paid less,
79 cents less to do the exact
same job is a guy which you know,
my opinion is fucked up. The job
should pay what you pay. Right?
So this guy says the wage gap statistic
that you hear about all the time is
simply the average earnings of
men and women working full time.
It does not take into account
different job positions, hours worked,
or different jobs.
It has nothing to do with the same work.
It has nothing to do with discrimination.
In 1963,
the supreme court passed
the equal pay act,
which makes it illegal to pay
different wages for the same job.
If you still don't buy that,
then consider this.
If a company could legally
play pay women less money,
do you think those greedy
cuts would ever hire a man?
Some decent points there. Uh, once I
pulled this wage gap threat thread,
a whole bunch of other feminists
myths started to unravel,
but I just wanted to shine a light on
this topic. Well, okay, lets you know,
I'll have to look all of that up. I never
looked up the equal pay act, but um,
if they're still able to make the
numbers work then wouldn't that say,
did guys get the better high
paying jobs then done then?
Does it become that? I'm
just asking. All right. Um,
that's what I would guess.
So I don't know.
Evidently I have some reading to do
and I think a lot of feminists do too,
that just jump on the bandwagon.
I'll look up the equal pay act.
MMM.
I don't know who the fuck knows.
I mean one of the dumbest fucking ways
to get somebody to listen to your goddamn
opinion is to just sit there and be like,
you got it better than us.
You're life is fucking easy.
That immediately puts the
other side going. Like,
you know, fuck you. Fuck you and your
procedure. You know, my fucking life. Cz,
I just dealt with this, this,
this and this. You know,
it just puts people into that mindset.
MMM.
I Dunno if that whole fucking yelling
and screaming and shit. You know,
believe me as a yeller and Screamer, I
know it doesn't make people listen to you.
It just makes you, people
just go, oh my God,
I want to get away from this person
or that person's a fucking lunatic.
That's been my experience
trying to convey ideas
since I was a little orange headed child.
MMM.
I don't know what's going on.
Okay. At the end of the day,
people show that the job should pay what
the job pays and the best person should
get it.
But sadly that is never going to happen
because there's always going to be the
boss's son.
There's always going to be the hot chick.
There's always going to be the racist,
the homophobe,
the person who comes in with the southern
accent, you're up north or vice versa,
and somebody mentally still fighting the
war or think southern people are stupid.
You keep, the only way to take the
human element out of it is to gradually,
slowly but surely dumbed down human
beings make everything automated and you
slowly replace them with
free thinking robots,
which is basically what's going to happen.
By free thinking.
I mean they agree with the upper 1% and
not even the upper 1% the upper 1% of
the 1% that doesn't even show
up. You know, there's a lot of,
remember all the blue blood money and
everybody kind of knew how much money they
had and now they all say that, oh
they gave away a lot. You know,
the Rockerfellers or you know, they,
their fortune is in what it's worth.
They used to be the Vanderbilts that
are only worth like $75 million. Now.
I mean that's,
I don't know,
there's all these stories out there that
there's families that are so fucking
big and powerful are above any sort
of borders and they fucking, you know,
when they traveled by yet,
it's only like,
it's like their little navy and they just,
it's,
I'd love conspiracy theory
and they just float around.
They pull up to the dock and the comp
countries just come out and give them bags
of gold and then they just disappear.
It's like waterworld except you know,
without the uh, you know, on set,
they still have all the amenities cause
the world hasn't flooded over yet.
Does that make any sense? You know, I
think that's a good spot to stop is any,
uh, my apologies for a fucking
up the podcast this week. Um,
you guys have a nice couple
of fucking days and um,
can I end on some more drum nerd shit.
I told you my uh,
drum teachers taken me
through, um, that sting album,
10 summers tails would have that has
the great Vinnie call Uda on it and how
they played in all these odd times,
but they wanted to imply for four times
and he finally taught me on that seven
days, which is in five, which I love. Uh,
he finally wrote out what he
was doing on the high yet,
which is basically he's playing
that it's four, four against five.
He's playing five underneath,
but he's implying four in the high hat
and a after all these fucking years of
trying to figure out how to do it.
He finally,
he just wrote out one line
of it and now it makes sense
to me and it's basically on the high hat.
I just still count in five.
But you just count,
you know, underneath if, if you listen to
it, you count one, two, three, four, five,
one, two, three, four, five
bumped, one dent that fucking shit.
But on top,
how it works for me is you just,
you just,
I still counted five. I
just, you're thrown in. He
counted is like eighth notes,
so one and two and three and four and
five and one and two and three and four
and five and the first time
through you accent one,
three and five and the second time
through you accent to in four.
Try that. That's the way I've
been doing it. But granted,
this is massively filtered down
from a professional drummer to a stand
up comedian who cannot read out loud.
Um, all right, that's it. Go fuck
yourselves. I'll talk to you on Thursday.
I'll check in on you.
All right.